the laws on what this means to the
individual whose privacy is violated in
the most horrible way but I think what
may be even more important is what this
means for democracy because spyware is
not just a technology it is a tool in a
broader toolkit the toolkit of the
authoritarian
it is a grave threat to democracy
because spyware is not being used
against you know just any citizen and
this is also why many people think oh it
doesn't concern me it concerns only you
know a handful of people that I have
nothing to do with no it concerns the
very people who are the custodians of
our democracy the people who hold power
to account the people who scrutinize the
people who exercise oversight
journalists oversight bodies lawyers
ngos researchers opposition politicians
and you know I firmly believe that
democracy is about checks and balances
and accountability and scrutiny take
those away
and democracy is dead
if you have no more counter failing
Powers then democracy is dead and that
is the very purpose of the regimes that
are using spyware against some of their
own citizens and this is not only
happening in Saudi Arabia or Mexico no
it's happening right here on our
doorstep within the European Union by EU
governments it is
a democracy crisis you might say
now but let's see a little bit what
happens since the news of this broke
which is now almost two years ago July
2021 when the Pegasus project presented
its uh its report
justice has not been done in a single
case
not a single case no inquiry be it
parliamentary or or judicial or police
inquiry has been concluded in a
meaningful way and not a single member
state has light been shed on the
situation
not a single case of illicit exports has
been investigated and not a single
license has been repealed colleagues
nothing has been done yeah some
countries have taken measures but in
most of the cases they are meaningless
or they even make matters worse
and I have to say the European Union has
also been pretty much absent with the
exception of this house and maybe the
European public prosecutor's office
letters have been written to the member
states asking them for explanations but
in a very friendly way now I I find the
contrast with the response of the
European Union to other crises quite
Stark you know we've had a we've had a
war we've had a pandemic we had
inflation we had an energy crisis but
long ago we had the banking crisis and
every time you know the European Union
is there with a crisis response in this
case the crisis is a democratic crisis
democracy is the core of what the
European Union is about and yet the
European Union is absent now today
their commissioner we are or tomorrow I
should say we are adopting a
comprehensive set of recommendations and
I would really ask the commission to
follow up
as much as you can really seek the
limits of your powers and in any case
report back in great detail to the
European Parliament preferably even
before the summer break about how you
intend to give a follow-up to our
recommendations because this is not the
end of our work friends this is where it
starts tomorrow we're going to adopt the
big Sledgehammer that will we will be
fighting authoritarianism with and we
will make sure that every single
recommendation is implemented no matter
how long it takes thank you very much
because thank you very much now on
behalf of the commission commissioner
renders
thank you madam president uh honorable
members
the commission should like to thank the
Pegasus committee for its report
on the presumed use of Pegasus and other
surveillance software in the EU we will
study the recommendations adopted by
your Parliament and we will give the due
follow-up to that I'm sure the council
will do the same even if the council was
not invited for this debate the
commission has watched the committee's
proceedings keenly throughout the course
of that time that it condemns any
illegal interference in personal
Communications
as it goes against democratic values and
undermines fundamental rights
we expect that National competent
authorities and courts make full use of
their powers
to topically investigate the allegations
regarding any unlawful surveillance
activities and to restore Citizens Trust
spyware is a particularly intrusive
technology
it is Paramount that the fundamental
rise to privacy and data protection as
enshrined in AU law are fully respect
all over the Union
the Lego framework governing the use of
spiral can differ depending on whether
its use falls under Au law or national
law
as previously stated where EU law
applies in the case of the use of
spyware confidentiality of any
Communications of individuals protected
by gdpr
and the directive on police and Justice
as well as on e-communications
authorities for surveillance in the the
national authorities are in charge of
monitoring this and making sure that
this legal framework is fully
implemented
EU law in data protection will continue
to apply when it comes to the use of
personal data by private entities even
if this treatment is necessary for the
use of National Security
similarly EU law applies also when
public authorities process any personal
data for repressive or penal purposes in
this way when law enforcement use any
type of spyware for this type of
objective the police Justice directive
applies
in this situation
individuals have the right to make sure
that their rights are uphold pursuant to
EU law that includes the right to
information as well as the right to
Legal redress the commission insists on
the importance of control authorities as
well as National legal authorities to
have the proper competence in order to
enforce just that it is essential that
these authorities fully Avail of all of
their powers for the purposes of fully
and in-depth assessing any violation of
Rights in this area
does not apply to cases where public
authorities directly access the data so
not via Telecom operator and process
them for General national security
purposes which is a different issue than
law enforcement
an important question in this debate is
therefore the delineation between the
application of aulo and National rules
on National Security as the payer
committee as I saw underlined
it is for the member states to Define
their National Security interests and to
adopt appropriate measures to ensure
their National and external security
nevertheless
the urban court of justice made clear
that member states must be able to
demonstrate that National Security would
be compromised in the case at issue
the court of justice also held that
threats relating to National Security
are the ones that are capable of
seriously
destabilizing the fundamental
constitutional political economic and
social structures of a country
such as terrorist activities
based on the court case law therefore
member states cannot merely refer to
National Security in a general way to
exclude the application of au law
in cases reported by the press the real
issue seems to be whether the use of
such a spiral is generally justified by
National Security in the individual
cases at hand
when such a restriction to the right to
privacy and personal data protection
cannot be justified as falling under
National Security
Au law must apply with all the
requirements it provides it is also
important to bear in mind that where Au
law is not applicable the European
convention on human rights still applies
as well as National constitutional law
safeguards
allowable members the commission has
been gathering information from all the
member states about the national legal
Frameworks governing the use of spyware
in order to examine the interplay with
au data Protection Law
most member states have replied except
the Netherlands and Hungary
and we are following up with member
states whose replies are still
outstanding
we are carefully analyzing the responses
received this exercise requires putting
member states responses in the context
of their relevant National framework it
is important to consider the following
points whether member states have in
place National legislation framing the
use of tools such as spyware for
national security purposes
whether the national legislation
provides for specific and sufficient
safeguards given the high level of
intrusiveness of the use of surveillance
tools
the report of the Pega committee
highlights the alleged use of spiral
against journalists in several member
states as you may recall this led the
commission to introduce specific
safeguards in the proposal for European
media Freedom Act
we propose a special provision to
further restrict the use of spyware
against media service providers and
journalists beyond the restrictions
applying to other forms of serbians
the discussions on this file are ongoing
in the urban Parliament and in the
council
The Proposal for a cyber resilience act
table by the Commission in September
last year also aims to address some of
the challenges of supply chain security
and to ensure that digital products
present on European market are
sufficiently sexual
we also acknowledge the concerns
regarding media reports about certain
member states exporting spyware to third
countries with authoritarian regimes
leading to possible human rights
violations
the new double-use regulation enforces
reinforced the reporting on export of
cyber security items including spyware
still member states are in charge of
granting export authorizations
according to the Ws regulation member
states are obliged to report individual
denials but not authorizations having
said that the commission continues
working with the member states to obtain
their Assurance of a proper
implementation of EU legislation
furthermore in line with the current
action plan on human rights and
democracy do you committed to uphold and
Advance human rights Around the World
online and offline the opinion position
regarding unlawful online surveillance
is firm States should Implement
legislations and safeguards to protect
people from unlawful servants including
any arbitrary or mass servants that may
be carried out by state actors in The
cyberspace as well as in the physical
world
any such policies have to be fully in
line with international human rights law
so of course I will now looking forward
to your debate and again the commission
will try to see how it's possible to
implement the recommendations that you
will vote at the end of such a debate
thank you
thank you commissioner
Mr Linus now has the floor
yes thank you Mr President uh as chair
of the committee I'm standing here with
mixed feelings today on the one hand I'm
proud of the work that we have done all
these meetings all these missions
spoken to over 200 interlocutors it
really has been a thorough investigation
I also congratulate the rupter and all
the Shadows on on the excellent result
on the other hand the findings of our
committee the facts that we've uncovered
paint a very troubling picture about the
abuse of spyware in our European union
and this spyware is a very invasive very
problematic piece of technology that can
be a powerful tool to fight criminals to
fight terrorists but if it's used in the
wrong way by governments with different
intentions it is a huge risk for rule of
law and democracy both at the national
and the European level and this is why
we need to address this and regulate
this
urgently and some of the recommendations
in the report I would like to highlight
first BioWare should always be subject
to an effective judicial authorization
and independent supervision instead of
banning spyware we should really make
sure that member states adhere to
certain requirements in using it like
investigating and resolving all cases
where alleged abuse or spyware is
relevant prove that the spyware
framework the regulatory framework is in
line with the standards of the Venice
commission and the case the case law of
the European court of justice cooperate
with Europe during these investigations
and repeal all export licenses that
breach the Dual use regulation in
addition when invoking National Security
grounds as you also mentioned
commissioner there must be a
justification member states should
demonstrate compliance with EU law
including the principles of
proportionality necessity legality and
legitimacy
now commission dear Mt chair of the
council I'm convinced that we have done
our job and we look to you now to take
this further and we'll be closely
watching you while you do so one last
Point president if you allow me a
personal note I was informed that last
weekend I featured prominently on Polish
state television and it's even
insinuated that I had direct links with
Putin now this is outrageous and it
shows two things two things
the Polish government
will stop at nothing to divert attention
from its attempt to abolish rule of law
in Poland and it means that our work has
a fact our measures that we propose are
so scary for the Polish government that
they resort to this kind of poisonous
tactic so let's make sure this only
abandons us to keep our work of scrutiny
even stronger in the future thank you
[Applause]
thank you
um thank you very much Hannah's Hyder
next thank you
thank you chair commissioner when the
Pega Committee of inquiry started its
work 14 months back we could hardly have
gauged the extent to which there was
unwarranted eavesdropping and
surveillance of politicians journalists
lawyers
and politically committed to people we
could not have extended could not have
predicted the extent of the use of plega
the use of this software and similar
software in these instances serve to
intimidate and silence critical actors
from the fields of politics and Civil
Society
all of these unacceptable uh Shenanigans
have had like to have said on them and
these going on are an existential threat
for democracy in the EU with our
recommendations to the commission and
the member states we wish to create to
the basis uh for according to stop to
the unwarranted use of spyware in Europe
such software should only be used to
fight serious crime subjected to a
judges warrant the commission must act
comprehensively and present a legal act
for the legal use of purchase
acquisition and passing on of spyware
and the stores were established common
Baseline standards now ex-colleague
Nicos Andrew luckis was spied upon by
the Greek government under the guise of
National Security this incidence really
does go to show that we require a
uniform definition of the concept of
National Security to prevent willy-nilly
construal of what national security
means we require protective measures for
particularly vulnerable professional
groups such as journalists we need
transparency legal aid for targeted
people and obligatory documentation to
trace the use of spyware Affairs of
National Security are in the purview of
a member states
fair enough but it is up to the EU to
insult and stand up for fundamental
rights which all member states have
committed to pursuant to the treaties
the implementation of our
recommendations is a scenery step to
rekindle the interest of European
citizens in our democracy and rule of
law
that's what keep eating hot next up was
our two note hohenstein
microphone for the speaker
does it oh
once again
thank you very much
this report and the recommendations of
the committee of inquiry take up more
than 200 pages and it is the
distillation of months of long work we
had more than 30 official meetings we
had fact-finding visits in six countries
we listened to more than 200 people Mrs
infelt has done a colossal job together
with a committee of inquiry and Analysis
an action plan but it's also an alarm
Bell that we want to sound vis-a-vis the
governments the human rights situation
and human rights has become a cyber
weapon against its own citizens this is
what they used in order to get to power
stay in power they set up a mechanism
that would ensure impunity but these
individuals not remain unpunished I
would like to thank the journalists and
activists that all can attributed
information in order to shed light on
this Scandal and make sure that it saw
the light of day we have a set of
actions enshrined here in the report and
recommendations to make sure that this
doesn't happen again and the
commissioner there will be a legislative
elections in Poland this year and I
would like to appeal to you commissioner
you need to implement one of the
proposals this European lab the European
lab will be responsible for checking the
situation and making sure whether online
or social networks communication
channels
lawyers journalists politicians aren't
aspired on using spyware we have to make
sure that during the next electoral
campaign the government doesn't use
Pegasus or other such Tools in order to
spy on the opposition thank you
come please come on
commissioner reinders dear colleagues
and too bad the council isn't here once
more because my speech actually
primarily addresses member states but
I'm sure they will receive the message
if one of your best journalists is spied
upon while investigating a major story
if one of your state prosecutors is
spied upon while preparing court cases
if your defense minister is spied upon
while attending NATO meetings if one of
your companies is exporting spyware to a
war zone if any of this happens and you
are only a halfway decent government
with some responsibility you would
investigate you would turn everything
upside down find the loopholes that make
this possible bring perpetrators to
Justice apologize to victims right
and I don't get why none of this happens
so basically we the Pega inquiry
committee did your job in the last 12
months yet rather than working with us
member states governments ignored or
obstructed our work the approach was
omerta
not Corporation
and looking at this mess I'm quite
Amazed by what we have achieved here and
I want to thank the reporter the Shadows
all members for that because we managed
to come forward with an accurate
description of the abuse that is
happening and with very solid and
reasonable recommendation on how to fix
it support it across party lines by
members by colleagues from 27 EU member
states
and if you ever wondered what the
European Parliament is good for
for this
Europe has been a Pioneer in protecting
the privacy of its citizens and asset
standards that have become Global ones
by now we bent the entire internet
ecosystem towards better protection and
respect of individuals data rights
hit on something
as horribly destructive as spyware it
looks as if we are lagging behind but
dear colleagues
if we want to see European and yes
Universal values reflected in the
regulation of these invasive
Technologies it is time to stand up to
the Shady practices of secret services
and to companies and their CEOs gone
wrong because otherwise the next chapter
of surveillance and manipulation then
involving Ai and other powerful
technologies will be very very dark we
have done our job commissioner now it's
time that you do yours the commission
and the council and believe me we will
follow up and follow up and follow up
until our recommendations are put in
place
thanks very much next up Dominic
taczynski
president to commissioner I thought we
would have a debate on the use
of
the technology in member states of the
EU but once again we are talking purely
and simply about Poland right from the
get-go at the commission leveled and an
assault on my a country of Poland
and I will have to fly the flag and
stand up for my government and my
country
the commissioner said
that that the
selling two-third countries by member
states was a scandal he said it was a
practice which would not occur but what
happens
Finn Fisher
this program Finn Fisher who's that
manufactured by by Germany
in the Munich specifically
and we've heard the accusation
accusations leveled at us by the
commission once again we did not
manufacture this type of program Poland
did not sell these programs to Morocco
the the
program was soldered to Morocco by
France but Poland is getting the stick
for this
we know all about the
various indicators of GDP at the
country's welcoming migrants and so on
and so forth we have a low GDP so we are
one of the weakest member states in the
EU we are under constant attack
our Long Live Poland hey guys miss Yoshi
ladies and gentlemen the decision to set
up a parliamentary committee for inquiry
on the use of spyware in Europe was a
sound idea I supported it because I
believe that the Europeans have the
right to know that what extent they've
been spied upon and who did it uh how I
truly believed that this committee would
be successful I put myself forward as a
member and I even put myself forward as
a coordinator for my group however today
I must admit that the results are
disappointing
of course
the report lists the different cases
spying in Europe and that's no mean feat
but I'd like to draw your attention to
several problems first of all the
organization of the fact-finding visits
we use the de Hunter rule in order to
select members that meant that I
couldn't go and no other ID members
could go to Greece or Cyprus
this is unacceptable because it's biased
and I think that democracy is part and
parcel of The credibility linked to a
committee of inquiry and then of course
there's a huge temptation to settle
accounts with certain governments
especially the Hungarian and polish
governments a lack of impartiality
causing to question the findings most of
which are exact and then of course
there's an attack against the concept of
National Security which is used as is a
reason for the use of uh spyware in
order to fight against terrorism I
believe that National Security should
stay within the remit of the member
states I don't think that there should
be something
um within the purview of the EU we are
also underestimating the need of member
states to use spyware especially to
fight against terrorism and organize
crime
the use of spyware can make sure that
other cases such as Samuel practice do
not happen again there is a suggestion
for a moratorium even though it's not
called that and I think that this
recommendation is flawed the committee
of inquiry wants to persuade the member
states to
vote in laws and make sure there are
safeguards that protect us against the
abuse of this in some countries such as
France have already done that and this
is a lofty objective but that doesn't
mean there should be a moratorium by way
of conclusion the committee of inquiry
disappoints us because of its lack of
prudence and objectivity thank you our
colleague next up Cornelia Ernst
first of all congratulations to the
rebel term who has done a good piece of
work because despite the blockage of the
member states the committee could find
that Poland Hungary Spain Greece
have used such spyware and Cyprus
is involved in trade in the single
Market we know that 14 member states
have used Pegasus under the guise of
National Society National Security and
finding
terrorism a disgraceful democracy the
um
the findings are important for all
victims whose rights have been infringed
the use of Pegasus is not
um can't be reconciled with fundamental
rights so a call for a ban on such
spyware and a strong message to all the
victims and all citizens
dear friends
it's about the commission drawing the
consequences for the member states
who are using this spyware and this is a
draft piece of legislation on the strict
use of spiteware as called for by the US
committee I call on you to act finally
next up regardless preach them all
presidents I want to start by thinking
the great work of the rapporters of
interwealth and the chairman of the
commutation on learners for taking on an
extremely difficult responsibility
Scandal is not about I.T nor security
nor regulation of the radioactive space
it is a scandal that strikes at the
heart of our democracy and the measures
we will pass will not guarantee its
protection for two fundamental reasons
first states are the main responsible of
this Scandal and one needs to have a
very good faith to assume that the
violators of fundamental rights
themselves
will be the ones responsible for
preventing future violations and second
Pegasus technology is incompatible with
the rule of law a technology that is
designed to escape all reliable and
independent control opens Pandora's Box
and what is to come will not be pleasant
all of you should get ready to see how
this technology will be used to
influence your political decisions if
this has not happened already in cases
such at the Spanish position on the
western Sahara thank you very much
thank you thank you
Vladimir Bill check
thank you Mr President commissioner
colleagues it was a privilege to work on
this report which I believe is already
becoming an important reference document
when it comes to dealing with gross
misuse of spyware
we must strike a healthy balance between
Security on the one hand and protection
of fundamental rights on the other hand
sophisticated spyware industry is a
relatively new phenomenon and Europe
must adapt to it
we need clear rules and safeguards to
protect our citizens journalists
politicians and activists
we also must be aware that this
technology can help us fight serious
crime and enhance our safety
we cannot simply stop technological
progress instead we must keep up and
deal with technological vulnerabilities
and expose those who do not play fair
we need clear rules for legitimate use
of spyware and we have to improve
fundamentally our existing checks and
balances and the judicial practice in
line with new technology this is the
main conclusion of our recommendation
and when it comes to misuse of spyber
colleagues
rule of law and legitimate use of modern
technology must always go hand in hand
we must for instance learn real lessons
from last elections in Poland and ensure
free and fair campaign without misuse of
invasive spyware this year and we must
stand by all victims of misuse of
spyware in Europe especially in
countries with weakening Democratic
institutions and lacking checks and
balances and Mr commissioner we count on
the commission to really work with us on
this thank you very much
thank you next up vice president
Katarina Bali
president president
commissioner colleagues
thank you very much for your question
for reasons of National Security
unfortunately we can't give you any
information
that was basically the standard answer
of the member states and their
governments to our questions on the use
of spyware
of course despite that we dug and we got
the information from other sources in
particular from journalists and ngos
what we found out was shocking
several governments have used this
spyware
to spy on various persons
um
Civil Society journalists prosecutors I
was in on a mission in Poland we were
with a prosecutor who was investigating
and
a lawyer a politician a trade unionist
in Greece we spoke with the chair of the
largest opposition party
and journalists
who
were also conducting investigations
these people
are supposed to have threatened National
Security what they were actually doing
was investigating critically this report
gives recommendations but what we need
above all is a legal framework it can't
be the case that we have rules for
everything
for uh what type of blogs and adapters
we have but how no rules on how these
devices are spied on it's not the person
themselves it's their families it's
their colleagues also it's the entire
um
all the contacts that they have and
people they know we have no definitions
of National Security and we don't have
any rules and we urgently need to change
that
floor is here
a microphone for the speaker please
president
dear colleagues
what we have on our mobiles what do we
look at what we scroll through what
private messages we write
we're talking here about a very personal
pieces of our data
but what if this mobile is subject uh to
hacking by Pegasus
spying software so that somebody uh can
read everything you do on your mobile
opposition politicians and journalists
in Europe have suffered this
this surveillance is a scandal for
Europe and in the committee of inquiry
in recent months we've done intensive
work to shed light on all of this we've
done a lot of work we've done a lot of
research in the committee of the inquiry
but the member states have not to play
to ball whatsoever and that's not
acceptable let's make this plain
in our recommendations we say we need
clear rules on spying software in Europe
and we call upon member states and the
commission to act
for good
thanks Theory thank you very much the
next speaker is saskia Brickman
foreign almost two years ago the
Forbidden stories Amnesty International
citizen lab Revelations on the illegal
use of Pegasus type
spyware triggered the work of our
committee of inquiry we spent hundreds
of hours listening to experts and
victims we organized fact-finding
missions we had Technical and political
negotiations and our committee inquiry
put forward sold recommendations to
ensure that such scandals didn't occur
again unfortunately our recommendations
are not binding and I'm very and I
regret this but they follow up what the
journalists have said and they're a key
stage in holding people accountable and
now something has to be done about that
we need to have a framework that
respects proportionality and necessity
and we need to protect fundamental
rights we have to exclude certain uses
situations and functions we have to
protect certain professions and we have
to make sure that victims have rights
and redress and there has to be a
European center of a technological
expertise and we should also have a
moratorium on these in the meantime when
it comes to evidence not everything is
allowed when it comes to surveillance
not even in the name of National
Security the use of spyware without any
framework or safeguards without
respecting fundamental rights democracy
and the rule of law uh have derailed
their lives have been destroyed and now
it is up to the European Commission in
the member states to take up our
recommendations and I also encourage the
national parliaments to put forward
their recommendations this Parliament
will breathe down your neck we are
expecting action and strong tax and
we'll be here to scrutinize their
implementation before we finish our work
in the vote in plenary I would like to
pay tribute to the victims of Pegasus an
equivalent spyware whose lives have
changed forever and they are still
harassed for speaking out for talking
about it and any suffering and damage
that they've had has to be it has to be
redressed and I would also like to pay
tribute to those journalists and human
rights Defenders that
shed light on the situation and that
allowed us to carry out the
investigations you are real Lookout
posts for human rights and we have to
continue this work working hand in hand
with you
thank you
the next speaker is asita kanko
thank you dear colleagues dear
commissioner dear president they say
dance like nobody is watching but text
an email like it will be displayed on
Instagram someday
perhaps we should not only see this as a
joke it is serious today not only big
brother is watching you
but also little brother to censor or to
feed this information to influence or to
destroy
how can our democracy survive and human
rights prevail
if the Press has lost freedom on the one
hand and critical reflects to question
things on the other hand the ideal
subject of totalitarian rule is not the
convinced Nazi or the dedicated
communist but the people for whom the
distinction between fact and fiction
true or false no longer exist
Hannah Arend wrote this long time ago in
modern Europe I would call that the
perfect recipe to kill a democracy from
the inside big brother is not what I
worry the most about French philosopher
Rafael Anthony calls the new threat
little brother little brother is
watching you so literally anyone can we
can make laws to tackle officials
pionage we cannot make laws to create
respect in society to do that we need to
have stronger Minds
thank you the next speaker is Georg Maya
president thank you president dear
colleagues
people are curious by Nature that's part
of parcel of Being Human our current
state of technical development is a
double-edged sword
revoted on artificial intelligence and
this is preceding a pace and we don't
know where AI precisely is heading
and it's hard for humans to gauge the
precise extent of the surveillance we
are subject to
for example
Poland is mentioned 30 times in Hungary
60 times in the report but the federal
intelligence agency in Germany used this
software too
I don't think we should have been blind
to what's happening in our own backyard
all of this is proceeding at a
cracking piece and this is reality for
for our citizens in the day-to-day life
we don't I want to
um
monitoring willy-nilly throughout the EU
there are so many Trojan horses floating
around even in the EP
we have heard about
uh MEPS
um
uh
having their files stored illegally for
18 months what is going going on with
this information this personal
information
elsewhere the data on MEPS was stored
I'm not leveling uh accusation so then
in particular party
there's a monster this the Leviathan is
prevalent everywhere colleagues and we
need to keep a keen eye out
foreign commissioner
I would like to warm journalists
including cypriot
journalists ngos witnesses that shed
light on Pegasus and Predator which
triggered this huge transparency
operation I would also like to thank the
rapporteur and the chair of the
committee because this has taken upon
European
European Dimensions we're talking about
a European framework that covers our
rights but when it comes to implementing
legislation everything collapses either
because of the use of national security
or other issues of course under this
issue of exporting spyware and which
means that people can rake in money and
I think it doesn't bode well for the
future because if you take into account
the fact that the European commission
and the council ignored us even worse
when it comes to Cyprus the
recommendations are stringent and the
European institutions and member states
have to take all of this into account
after 15 months of hard work the issue
of surveillance isn't going to end when
we vote tomorrow on the contrary this is
only the beginning
the next greatness the next speaker
is Mr zoido Alvarez
if we've learned anything over the past
year is it's that Spider-Man like
Pegasus are very dangerous tools these
are the tools which are Security
Services need to use to Grapple with
threats such as terrorism drug smuggling
and organized crime or attempts to
undermine the Constitutional order that
these tools must be used in compliance
with what's laid down by the rule of law
this is something which does not not
happen in countries such as Hungary and
Poland where we've heard about abuses
against it lawyers
journalists and members of the
opposition for party political reasons
many efforts have been made by the Greek
government to step up its legal
framework to avoid a repetition of such
things in future in Spain
uh we broke apart of the Catalan
independent movement under mining uh
this many state Spain is fulfilling all
EU level standards with the appropriate
uh legal checks and balances with rule
of law we've established links between
uh in in independent the dependence
minded in Spain and Putin we've called
upon the sunset government to explain
what happened with the bugging of
ministers mobiles we still don't know
what was removed from the prime
minister's mobile
and why in the EP and we call upon the
appropriate authorities to shed light on
this that's me do you accept the blue
card
do you accept the blue card
a blue card
no
you don't accept it
our next speaker our next speaker is
thank you very much
the urban government
has again
has shown
itself from
given a bad image of yourself
in this affair in the paragus affair
they've shown that they're not able
to
recognize the rule of law so
Urban
is not getting funds from Europe the
urban government can't govern inflation
on food is four times the average in
Europe
the urban government
is concentrating on
instead of giving proper information to
Citizens they're just issuing propaganda
with the help of spyware
citizens journalists
and business people are being
eavesdropped and intimidated colleagues
commissioner
that is the sad lesson that we find in
Hungary
thank you very much there's a key
message that I would like to put across
today is security yes but not at any
price
spyware is necessary in the fight
against
terrorism and crime but we also have to
make sure that member states don't use
National Security as a pretext and hide
behind that in order to carry out
illegal spying on activists journalists
opposition and so on now the committee
of inquiry investigation showed us that
we needed two things a better knowledge
and development of this technology in
Europe in order to protect our citizens
especially if there is a worsening rule
of law situation around the world and
other threats but we also need solid
safeguards to make sure that
human rights are respected at the same
time as security so this isn't the end
of a committee's work but the beginning
of what needs to be followed for the
European project thank you
I would like to start with the following
my blue card was not accepted I would
remind you that Pegasus can only be used
fighting against organized crime and
terrorism in your statement you cast
your net far too wide
as a member of this Committee of inquiry
and also as a Grassroots citizen who was
spied on I am fairly satisfied with the
recommendations we will be voting on
tomorrow and right now I would like to
stress the Sterling and tremendous
efforts made by the rapporteur and the
two and by most members of the committee
of inquiry
and we had our work cut out for us there
was political ziggery pokery going on
protection of national interests and
double standards these were all
constants over these months of inquiry
it was disgraceful
in the mission to Spain Spain the the
country where there was the greatest
number of aspiring in Europe it was
removed from the purview of the
committee thanks to pursue
they did their level best
but to thanks to everybody's consistency
Catalan gate is at the Forefront of this
report her mission was conducted a
mission which many feared and Spain was
and Poland and Hungary and Greece and
Cyprus were branded as the champions in
stamping on people's human rights
the floor is yours
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
the Pega committee
can't be called a committee of inquiry
to use that name it must have the
corresponding powers for example access
to secret information
you had no access to many documents
and so the conclusions
to some extent
can be amended and I have the impression
that you
it was created for a particular reason
for example
um against Poland or Hungary the goal of
this committee was never to have an
objective
goal or to make legislative proposals
because the European Union has no powers
here it was only a political goal
against Poland and Hungary an attack on
them
therefore
they were very controversial Witnesses
who were asked persons who are
searched by the state prosecutors who
I should explain what they're up to
that against the background of the
hunger the Ukraine war there are more
important things
the European peoples were no longer
tolerate meddling in their private lives
in societies where we promise more and
more freedom and these specific freedoms
are often trampled upon the list of
countries using the Pegasus spy fair is
horrifying and the report describes the
fact that more than 75 countries have
bought the this kind of software on the
30th of May 2021 a Danish newspaper
talked about what the NSA had been doing
and eavesdropping and spying there
Angela merku and others had been spied
upon by the United States through
Denmark did the EU take any measures to
protect the EU leaders from U.S spying
no it never did did the EU come up with
a system to protect this economic
interest
against the U.S predators no so so
then we had the of course the terrible
Revelations of Edward Snowden in 2013
let me remind you that Snowden said that
the U.S was spying on more than 35
leaders around the world this was
recently confirmed by the former French
prime minister Francois
he appeared before a committee of
inquiry in the National Assembly of
France and he said together with Nicolas
Sarkozy the eavesdropped on me it was
the NSA the EU always prefers to attack
Hungary Poland or Morocco they prefer to
do that instead of to defy the United
States of America in a parliament that
managed to never deal with U.S meddling
in its special committee on the matter
then nothing surprises me yes member
states have to invest to better regulate
the private actors that provide more
performing tools to for surveillance but
there will always be companies somewhere
in the world that will provide these
Services I'm very sorry to see that the
solutions include in giving the European
commission more Powers over the member
states the time has come for the member
states to make sure that they take over
their own National Security
madame infelt
thank you chair Mr Mariani um I I was
part of the investigation into the uh
and Zay wire tapping and I share your
frustration about the fact that the
European Union hasn't done anything
about it
oh
my English is not perfect sorry I hope I
will have French translation
okay right okay so I would say I mean
you were you were frustrated that after
the revelations of the NSA spying
Etc that nothing has been done by the
European Union you said why doesn't the
European Union act but then my question
is why are you your party and your group
opposed to giving the powers to the
European Union to act because you've
tabled amendments and you've you know
during the debate you have opposed
action by the European Union so are you
now reproaching the European Union for
being too weak or too strong
I had not the chance to be member of
this committee how many times how long
times I have
um
I have 30 seconds I wasn't in your
committee sorry but I think the problem
for the European Union is just the week
because we are strong with the weak
people and weak we are the strong State
you have a new example we accuse Poland
Hungaria maroc but excuse me what in the
past we did in front United States when
the lesson the people of Europe nothing
we're very pleased to see you here for
once
because for a whole year and a half even
though we had scandal after scandal
after Scandal the European commission
was completely absent we didn't get a
single statement and during this time
period we were under attack
of Russia
me as as an enemy of the people the
catalans we have here denied now as
enemy of the people where mrsophy inved
the uh the reporter was daily attacked
by the Greece by the Greek uh per
government media you know as Madame
Sophie you know we attack after attack
we had nothing now now it's time
it's time for the commission to do its
job you know and take their
recommendation seriously and follow if
the member states will uh will implement
the recommendations thanks
for
Opera ladies and gentlemen
with regard to programs such as Pegasus
in fighting against terrorism they ought
to be used they are important but they
should not be drawn upon to fight
against the political opposition this is
something which has to be swept aside
European commissioned if not we will
have no due Democratic processes and no
Democratic elections
the the scandals
already mentioned
the head of the Electoral board in
Poland was a targeted by that's by where
his devices were bugged they should not
happen again there are cases in other
member states similar to this therefore
we require a directive which applies
throughout the EU so that we can have
some cast iron guarantee for the
security and safety of citizens as well
as electoral freedom
now
when the state TV station
shows a certain material
when State channels show a person on
their screens that means this person is
very important so Mr Leonard's
popped up on a Polish TV so that's a
good signal or to be proud of that you
did Sterling work it's an honor
the next speaker is Mr Lopez Aguilar
reindeer
commissioner Rangers for a whole long
year the committee of inquiry on Pegasus
worked very hard and came up with
conclusions and what's the point of the
conclusions that the commission has to
take an initiative and come up with
European legislation so some area some
issues don't come up again don't occur
again so the use of spyware in order to
Black model the opposition lawyers
prosecutors journalists among others and
the freedom press that should be banned
we need an export ban to repressive
regimes and we also need to call for a
de facto moratorium to cover the export
or this or to revoke export licenses
until we get common standards that make
sure that there is effective legal
redress and judicial review when spyware
is used and fundamental rights are
violated for any other case apart from
the investigation a very serious crimes
and then we need a national security
definition and standard so that it
cannot be invoked
without necessity and proportionality
enshrined in the charter fundamental
Rises respected thank you very much okay
and the next speaker is Clement grossel
Vani
the findings of the bigger committee
have shown that despite democracy no one
is immune to
misuse of new technologies if we
actually
are to believe the citizen lab Slovenia
is no exception of course we should have
technologies that would be used legally
because they can help us in our fight
against terrorism and organized crime
but despite these benefits what we need
is to prevent any abuse or misuse by
private companies or by state actors so
personal data the most intimate data
that are collected via these
Technologies are not a commodity used by
politicians or anyone else these
Technologies do not respect state
borders that is why we need uniform
norms and standards at the EU level also
these standards should be used to punish
such abuse if we don't do that we will
actually live in the novel 1984.
thank you
Gwendoline delpos Caulfield is the next
speaker
this
we can draw three lessons from the Pekka
committee we need a moratorium and
regulations for this new technology as
for arms these are intrusive devices
in the hands of though in power and
and they'll suspect for Citizens they
are secret terrifying ongoing
surveillance second conclusion in the EU
States
with a week for finances have a
surveilled activists or
opponents to silence them no
transparency no redress for for victims
Hungary uh Poland Cyprus and at least
and Spain
rich countries like France or Germany
don't need to buy uh Israeli sites by
way they can do it themselves
and we know nothing about that
see thank you
thank you very much commissioner thank
you to Sophie and 12 for her report one
year later we would have liked to come
up with a response but we have a lot of
myth and Legend people expect answers
people hope that democracies won't have
to deal with this kind of a front we've
got Pegasus and others and it's given
ideas to the French Senate with the
adoption of article 3 of a new law now
trampling on our rights has become their
dogma and it is our duty to defend
ourselves against this is this what we
really want for our children you are
their Muses Our Lives their lives are in
their interest
now we need this kind of counterweight
becomes a threat and yet they are the
pillars of our democracy we have to be
careful
these practices are chronicled Death
Foretold because we're talking about the
crazy authoritarianism of a handful
thank you
and the next speaker Mr President Mr
commissioner it's extremely boring
development that illegal surveillance
has taken place in the EU member states
certain web states have used Pegasus and
equivalent spyware against journalists
politicians diplomats lawyers Civil
Society actors that is totally
unacceptable
that Pegasus committee has been
investigating during last year
unfortunately it has been often very
challenging because it has been very
difficult to collect data for the Becca
report from all member states in
appropriate manner
clear rules are needed here spyware
surveillance should remain the exception
and always require effective binding and
meaningful prior theoretical
authorization by an impartial and
independent theoretical Authority it
must be ensured that the measure is
necessary proportionate and strictly
limited to cases affecting National
Security on involving terrorism or
serious crime
we know that technology enables access
to all data also retroactively therefore
appropriate limitations and safeguards
must be in place
all member state governments and member
State parliaments have not provided the
European Parliament with meaningful
information about their legal Frameworks
governing the use of spyware
it's imperative that member states now
resolve these unclarities that have been
discovered during this investigation
thank you miss you guys write them the
floor is yours
foreign
colleagues in the EP lawyers in Hungary
there is a whole swathe of people who
have been subject to spyware spyware
used against the people who are
conducting their work and standing upper
for their ideals we're talking about
and the important people by spyware is
crossing her borders it's disseminated
throughout the EU and that's a threat to
our rule of law and democracy
member states more often than not have
undermined our inquiry by by quoting
National Security interests but we're
talking about the individual freedoms of
EU citizens we have issued clear
recommendations uh to the commission
here member states must have Protected
Their citizens and not to spy on them
thank you very much to the rap or two
and uh thank you to the chair of the
committee for their sound collaboration
communist Security Services and
refine every free voice
buying everyone's private life including
the places where people lived we have
thin walls and neighbors listening in on
your conversations
today in the European Union we
unfortunately have cases in which the
authorities are doing the same thing
with modern means this is the most
anti-democratic action that a government
can take so congratulations to the
rapper tour Sofia tweldt for her
excellent work in her report we now know
exactly how the this technology works
but we have recommendations in order to
end these practices the gas's project
has shown that at least 180 journalists
have been spied on in the world
Europe can go down a slippery slope if
the people who are in the public service
and who want to reveal the truth are
endangered by this technology we now
have the media Freedom Act that allows
us to act uh and to implement these
recommendations we have to say that it
is forbidden to spy on journalists
um we they are not obligated to reveal
their sources and we respect them this
is an obvious step that we should take
for the safety of journalists and of our
democracies
stop spying on us
stop doing it illicitly illegally
intrusively and in an anti-democratic
spirit
every time that governments or european
State agencies have bugged the mobiles
of politicians activists to journalists
or lawyers they have gradually worn away
our democracy and rule of law any
assault on our phones is an assault on
the fundamental rights of everybody and
now I would like to directly address the
Spanish state stop spying on us and to
play a ball with the investigations the
victims of your illegal surveillance we
all have the right to know why and how
we respond on and people must be held to
account uh it's not just me asking for
this this is also been climate fought by
the European Parliament today asking
Spain to cooperate with the courts
famous to issue warrants if there are
any and Spain must give a response to
all of the victims of Catalan gate and
who cannot hide behind the pretext of
National Security we are not a threat we
are Democrats Mr thoidel and if we are
deemed to be a threat it's because your
concept of democracy is extremely flimsy
and their message also to the extreme
right box
none of the extreme rights is in the
chamber
let's stop using paranoid and a toxic
rhetoric you're not hoodwinking anybody
you're the constant undermining efforts
of your group will not prevent us
calling him on the Spanish estate and
all the States involved in this Scandal
uh to pay reparations and uh these
states must not repeat this exercise
please
thank you president ladies and gentlemen
I listened carefully to this debate
I've taken note
of the activities of the committee ahead
of this debate I'd like to thank
colleagues for their work I'd like to
thank the reporter and the chair of the
committee
because sometimes it's not the case that
the committee of inquiry arrives at a
clear conclusions
and the causes of the problem it's clear
that after the adoption of
recommendations of the commission is
necessary to have a European reaction
member states notably those
who are suspected of having abused
Pegasus spyware
would like to adopt legislation which
prevents it and that is the case
where we must call for European measures
call on the council and the commission
to
to carry on the work so that it doesn't
end with recommendations of the
parliament it's
we need to have very strict rules
for legal redress to be effective we
must delimit
the reasons
for serious crimes where this spyware
can be used if we underestimate the
gravity of this question it could be
dangerous in the long term
as has been mentioned in the debate
so I fully support the recommendations
by the committee
foreign
a second Bavaria but instead of that
we're becoming a second East Germany
he's given the green light to his
friends to spy on polish Patriots
Senators president konovsky others as
well
the law and Justice party is treating
them
as if they were from Al-Qaeda
who were being told that Pegasus is
being used for security reasons how can
you talk about security when for six
months you didn't manage to find the
Russian missile how can we talk about
security when you attack polish generals
what are you talking about
the e
yeah we have an EU Poland isn't
stuzzyland you cannot gloss over the
truth here you cannot hide the truth you
think that there will be impunity but
you're gonna have you're going to be
held accountable in Autumn because
Poland isn't the law and Justice party
next up Jordy canyas
from from the get-go we've said that the
work of the special Pegasus committee
could be tapped into uh by people to
undermine democracy and rule of law or
could be tapped into by the penguin to
pursue its anti-european strategy we
said there was a risk of Pegasus
becoming a trojan horse
and that some people would open the door
to this horse we avoided this in the
report voted through in the committee
this text which a glosses over the all
wooliness and uh draws on actual
evidence we have come up with that
resolution which will be voted through
in the plenary resolution containing
tons of what matters to guarantee the
the rights and freedoms of European
citizens
um however
we must emphasize the fact that we must
in short there are guarantees that all a
member states use all possible
mechanisms all possible tools and all
available technology to stand up for our
democracies
a state must stand up for its citizens
using surveillance
um techniques of which that's only
spyware if there is no legal warrant
okay just thank you next up
thank you president
dear commissioner
absent Council
abuses of spyware
to break into Mobile phones of a
position
politicians journalists activists but
also ordinary citizens recording
everything the victims do what they say
who they meet gaining access to their
videos and photos email anything stored
on their devices your colleagues were
speaking about the European Union
we know for sure that there are multiple
governments in Europe who acquired these
Technologies
but where the shock starts is the
undeniable evidence that some
governments abuse spyware to spy on
their opponents and seriously undermine
the rule of law and the trust of
citizens in democracy in their countries
that must stop now even though I believe
that we need a ban on the use of such
Technologies the compromise we reached
is a good start and going into a good
direction but our work is not done the
ball is now in the hands of the
commission and the national governments
please act thank you
Mr eichen tommark
is
your next step
Mr Speaker Mr commissioner dear
colleagues
in less than a year
European citizens will go to the polls
again to choose the representatives in
the European Parliament
can the EU guarantee that these
elections will be free and legitimate
because these uh spyware programs have
already proven their efficiency in
manipulating electoral processes the
misuse of these programs means more than
just an invasion into private life it is
a real threat against the state's
security let's remember how much harm
disinformation and propaganda from
Russia have caused
these are very powerful weapons used at
a large scale by people who want to
silence the opposition uncomfortable
journalists and critics and trample on
Liberty and democracy
it's obvious that the European
institutions have to do more and have to
be braver and more and firmer in order
to make sure that these weapons are not
delivered directly to the hands of the
enemies of democracy and freedom of
expression
European citizens will go to the polls
trusting that their voice will be heard
and that the result of their vote will
be fair and not manipulated or altered
in any way that is why we need more
transparency and safety in order to gain
the Citizens Trust thank you
thank you
thanks silvikion over to you
thank you very much tomorrow we'll be
voting on the recommendations put
forward by the committee of inquiry that
will help us fight against the illegal
use of spyware in Europe warm thanks to
Sophie and Hannah's for all the work
done over the last 14 months we're
talking about visits hearings often very
technical but extremely informative
and now this has all come to an end I'm
sorry that there isn't an immediate
moratorium even though this report is a
solid basis for the rights of European
citizens the set of recommendations put
forward are going to have to be fleshed
out through legislation because we hear
of misuse every day and this technology
is developing in Leaps and Bounds now
the member states mustn't take these
recommendations lightly they have to
take specific measures in order to
respect the protect the rule of law and
democracy thanks to the S and D there we
are requesting a clear definition of
National Security as a reason to justify
the use of spyware when it is used
against journalists political opponents
other others I think this is an
extremely important Point National
Security should only be used as a last
resort with very stringent safeguards
[Applause]
thank you chair commissioner dear
colleagues well the Pegasus Scandal
broke two years ago and unfortunately
this Parliament is still among the very
very few political voices who refuse to
let it be swept under the rug
but we have to come from the reality EU
governments are using military Grace PIV
arrogance journalists and critics just
imagine a reporter trying to work to
hold the government accountable in
Hungary ministers are literally
cordoning themselves off and do
everything to avoid answering critical
questions
and as a thank you yet again for the
public service the journalists are doing
well they have their life invaded and
their phones tab every intimate detail
every family photo every private
conversation is now subject to deprying
eyes and ears of those in power and
colleagues this is totalitarianism and
we can never ever accept that this is
happening today in the European Union
and I thank the rapporters have been at
12 for her Relentless fight for Eagle
level action with this resolution we
demand common standards clear
limitations on targets and robust legal
remedies for the victims it is the bare
minimum for a functioning democracy
thank you
Miss evenings here the floor is yours
colleagues it is unbelievable how these
spyware's programs are being used
against innocence
people imagine a spyware program that in
secrecy reads your messages listens to
your phone calls collects your passwords
follows your every move have access to
your microphone and camera for that sake
and steals information from your phone
well since some time back we know that
we do not need to imagine it the Israeli
spy cyber intelligent firm Pegasus
spyware is here and has been used and
that is what the recommendations and the
report is very very clearly State
stating but on what ground the license
access is given to whom it's given and
who it is being used against we have
less knowledge on illegal and total
groundless surveillance is one of the
biggest threats against our Democratic
European Union it is therefore
unacceptable that Pegasus and other
equivalent systems are being used
against Civil Society organizations or
positions journalists and dissidents and
unfortunately I am not surprised that
the situation is worse in Hungary and
Poland the situation is alarming to the
extent that all of us MEPS were
encouraged to check our phones we need
to take total control over these systems
to ensure integrity and privacy thank
you thank you very much our next speaker
is Mr Pat goldthies the floor is yours
thank you chair the commissioner it
makes perfect sense that some EU member
states use commercial spyware to fulfill
legitimate law enforcement requirements
that's not the problem the real problem
of course is like the reporter said that
some EU member states use this spyware
to discredit the Democratic opposition
and kill democracy in Europe Poland
Hungary Greece shame on them and I have
a triple call to action to the
commission first since it is often the
Israeli government signing export
licenses for the spyware used to kill
democracy in Europe the EU should exert
significant pressure on Jerusalem to
Halt such exports secondly
together with our American friends the
EU should put forward primary and
secondary sanctions to entities who sell
the rule of law to rule of law violators
put these companies out of business and
last but not least let me remind the
commissioner that it was the brilliant
Canadian NGO citizens lab who disclosed
the Pegasus spyware Scandal here in
Europe in the first place where the
commissioner where is it European
equivalent to investigate such technical
technical operations my Amendment to the
European Body it had already has already
created a budget line to create such an
institution it's now up to you to follow
up and make it happen thank you
thank you
our next speak is papatakis
the Pegasus Scandal the Predator Scandal
and the scandals related to others
spyware has shown that democracy is
being eroded and of course it has put
the fact that human rights are being
violated in the spotlight unfortunately
these type of systems are weren't only
used for National Security or in order
to fight against terrorism but also for
the surveillance of political opponents
as was the case with the leader of the
pasok party Nicos Andrew luckis and
journalists who were just doing their
job properly in Cyprus were still
waiting for specific answers from the
competent National authorities
oh were they using the spyware who are
they spying on since 2000 we've been
waiting for answers since 2019 but
unfortunately there's been a suspicious
silence we all know that this spyware
were on the market as if they were just
normal consumer goods
what we have to do now is not just to
make sure that they can only be marketed
under straight conditions but that
member states also punish those who
violate democracy
thank you evoke this stuff
Mr chair the Pegasus affair
has shown that technology corrupts
morality and creates opportunities for
abuses opportunities which human nature
cannot resist spite or spyware is
increasingly blurring the boundary
between democracies and dictatorships
because the psychology of those in power
is the same regardless of the political
system Pegasus invades everyone's
privacy and the raises the rights and
freedoms which our laws Proclaim our
laws protect the individual and Pegasus
destroys the very notion of the
individual and turns it into a
transparent mass of data that can be
abused by those in power and those with
a vested interest
processes that they wrote Democracy
exist in a number of EU countries
despite the existence of safeguards
cases of illegal use are growing at a
break neck base that is why I welcome
Parliament recommendations for political
and institutional reforms to provide
reliable guarantees of our rights
they're part of the battle for the
future of our democracies HDI system I
have four colleagues who are interesting
to take the floor I will start with
matamulut Miller Novak
thank you very much for giving me the
floor chat
dear commissioner dear colleagues
politicians of any colors of all colors
from all countries are tempted to gain
power or to stay in power also with
illegal and inadmissible means during
the Pega committee we have also found
out that democratically elected
governments in Democratic member states
have been acted completely in a
non-democratic fashion while they were
actually spying on their citizens also
we have been focusing on individual
member states and there was tension
there was incrimination among MEPS
coming from different member states from
different political parties within the
same member State this also shows that
what we need is a European
legal framework and control of member
states so that they will actually
respect democracy and human rights
thank you Anders please
I thank you president commissioner and
colleagues I'd like to congratulate the
repertoire for the extremely thorough
work done on the revealing the extent
and methods of the use of commercial
spyware the report concludes that many
of these companies are registered in
Ireland without any substantial presence
such as office space or employees one
such spyware company is registered to
accompany formation specialist at an
office in the center of Dublin according
to the currency and online publication
this company sold its spyware to the
rapid support forces in Sudan the
successor to the genocidal janjuice the
Irish parliament's Justice committee has
agreed to my request that hearings take
place on whether it is appropriate that
such companies are registered in Ireland
I say this to illustrate that if the
council won't act National parliaments
have a critical role to play to call out
the failure to regulate to protect and
Safeguard our citizens and our democracy
thank you
foreign the outer muscle recover to you
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
commissioner
the Pega committee
should
concentrate on risks
facing the European Union and they
shouldn't concentrate on others
here we have the impression that it's
just Poland and Hungary
who are using this software
illegally
to act against the opposition
that's not true
there are very good safeguards in Poland
according to the committee and there is
judicial control on all spying
activities
so everything is
being done legally
member states should be able to use
these Technologies because terrorists in
these days have modern devices and
software
and we must be able to defend ourselves
against that
it's about the European Union
having its own powers
like Wallace
we welcomed a report on the use of
Pegasus it makes for shotgun but not
surprising reading
on the actions of the apartheid state of
Israel and the use of Pegasus software
is a matter of diplomacy with a report
highlighting how the sale of Pegasus
software is used as a diplomatic
bergmanship where country is turning a
blind eye to Israel's actions
domestically
the report also highlights how numerous
EU members States fully engage in the
industry on my own country Ireland the
report States Ireland offers favorable
fiscal arrangements to a large spyware
vendor
if we're serious about strictly
regulating the use and trade of spyware
we must first start in our own backyard
and ensure that EU member states are
prevented from promoting and
profiteering of a product that
essentially amounts to mass surveillance
over to you
feed and Duncan
um
ladies and gentlemen I'd like to thank
you for this debate
during which a number of important
issues have been raised asking for your
request for the member states
I
recognize that the council has not been
invited to for this debate
the commission has been very clear for
that all attempts by member states to
illegally access information
is inaccessible if it's confirmed when
it comes to the conduct of the
commission I'd like to point out
I've had the uh I've responded to
various invitations to your you know
committee
or when it comes to the use of pegas in
Spain or predator in uh
Greece which I discussed with the
government on the spot I asked for
information from the member states
that member states should supervise and
control their security services to make
sure that they fully respect fundamental
rights
including the protection of personal
data security of journalists and the
freedom of expression
because to all the member states about
the legal framework governing the use of
spyware in order to examine the
interplay with au data Protection Law we
ask a series of questions including the
purposes under which spyware is
permitted for law enforcement purposes
for National Security or other purposes
the relevant safeguards that are
applicable where a spyware is used for
law enforcement and for national
security purposes with full respect for
the principles of proportionality and
necessity it is not the strength forward
exercise given the diversity of the
response received it also requires
putting member states responses in the
context of their relevant National
framework we continue to analyze the
responses based on the report and
recommendation of the Pega committee as
well as our all fact Gathering exercise
the commission will decide on the most
appropriate way forward to better
protect the citizens thank you
thank you
thank you that
we will finish with the wrap Hotel
Sophie that felt thank you chair thank
you commissioner thank you colleagues
for this debate we have often referred
to this Scandal as a Watergate the
European or Greek or Spanish or
Hungarian equivalent of Watergate
actually it isn't it's like this movie
called the lives of others which is
about the former Eastern European uh
stazi spying on its citizens a
repressive regime that is what this is
about and colleagues do we actually
learn from history or are we doomed to
make the same mistakes over and over
again do we close our eyes and ears
until it's too late and then we have to
start all over again with rebuilding
democracy because we are not immune to
authoritarian Tendencies simply because
we're European we have to fight for it
and here
commissioner I would like to appeal to
you the European Union has to act and it
has to give itself the powers to act
because quite frankly relying on
National authorities for upholding the
law
when those very same National
authorities are the actual perpetrators
makes absolutely no sense
you know
thank you I got a bit choked up here
the thing is that you you very often put
the burden on the shoulders of the
individual saying yeah but people you
know victims can go to court but then
you're putting the burden on the
individual the burden of upholding EU
laws that is not a replacement for
enforcement by the EU commission and the
other uh EU bodies
then on National Security National
Security is very important but it has
become a blanket exemption to the
Democratic rule of law it is very
important that we get a clear
demarcation whether it is a unified
European definition or the obligation
for a member states to Define but there
has to be a a definition of National
Security
commissioner this is a full-blown
Democratic crisis and therefore we need
a crisis response not a technocratic
legalistic and timid reaction we need to
act as we did in the other crisis as I
have said before because commissioner
this is my last sentence chair
not a thousand democracy action plans
can save our democracy if we just stand
by and watch how it is being destroyed
there is a broad majority for the
recommendations please commissioner act
on this with all the strengths that you
have thank you
[Applause]
thank you foreign
The Joint debate is closed the vote will
be held tomorrow
the next item on the agenda is the
council and commission statements
make Europe the place to invest
and once again I would like
to invite The
Residency of the council Jessica Roswell
to take the floor
thank you president honorable members
commissioner